this program is brought to you by Emory
University
so there actually is a whole
conversation already going on amongst
people about how would you know when a
robot was at the point that it had
enough of a sense of itself and its
independent existence that it deserved
some kind of rights and it is not
unconnected by the way to the great ape
debate this is all part which where
they're trying to suggest that maybe
gorillas and chimpanzees and some of the
great apes also deserve certain levels
of rights because they seem to have most
of the qualities that we think you know
they suffer they project into the future
they love their children and things like
that
it will be an interesting question and
and it won't just be an intellectual
question because one of the fascinating
things about robots is there's been a
whole series of experiments that show if
you create a robot that moves but just
looks like a whole bunch of gears and
you give someone a sledge hammer and say
smash it they'll smash it if you put a
little furry cover on it so now it moves
but it looks organic or it looks more
organic they won't hit it and so as soon
as you begin to make robotic forms look
more like organic forms whether you make
them humanoid whether you make them more
animal appearing people are very very
reluctant to harm them so we already
have robots that in one sense or another
are being treated like animals not like
robots right because really there's no
reason not to smash a robot I mean
except for the expense of it it's no
different than smashing your toaster
right nobody would say oh it's wrong to
smash your toaster and yet as soon as
you begin to give the appearance of of
some sort of life to robots
people begin to project onto it the
feelings that they project onto life so
as robots get more and more
sophisticated as they look more and more
humanoid emotionally we're going to
begin to want to treat them more like
human beings and that's why the question
is so difficult because there is the
question of when do they deserve it
divorce from our emotional reaction to
that when do they actually
reach the point of having an internal
life for example and that we don't
really know the answer to that because I
know that I haven't I know that you have
an internal life or that anyone watching
this has an internal life because I have
one and I'm a human being in your in
human being so I assume you have one too
but when you start from scratch to try
to create a thinking creature the moment
when that creature has an internal life
versus can answer all your questions in
such a way that a person with an
internal life does and is there a
difference between those two things is a
very very difficult question and one
that people who think about these
whether they're philosophers or
roboticists we just don't know the
answer to that game
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University